[Music]
[Music]
we're the editorial team here at glamma
and today we're going to be styling at
the Fiat 500 in aid of lady garden so
guys if we're gonna style this today
let's think about some stuff like colors
and shape and it's like a really fun
cool car I actually love it if you like
the type of person who wants to buy this
is really fashionable and stylish yes
absolutely
I've got her illustrates it my name is
agus Tina
so this is a word super I think modern
sort of like how she depicts women I
feel like we need some of this on the
car amazing the glamour II definitely
fun yeah yeah my adventurous things
nicely to fear because I feel like style
individuality yeah a car is not just the
car is part of a look at 500 owner wants
to turn heads yeah you know having the
freedom to express your individuality
glamour is about diversity I want to
make sure that's included in the motya
we need to come up with this look it's
something that's quite classic colorful
or oh my god I like a camera on the hook
it's a Ming ray bag okay awaits me some
good headphones right Ivan is love this
t-shirt and I love the message from
Victoria back yeah it's a little bit
smarter a little bit more chic a staff
that she beat ooze I don't really like
pink
[Music]
but like we got across the personalities
of glamour it was a really great day
it's really fun
[Music]
[Music]